this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and today we're back in a galaxy
far far away
as he takes a look at the weapons of
star wars battlefront 2.
so the last of the um iconic star wars
weapons
is boba fett's blaster and was built by
baptian co
on a weberly and scott signal pistol
if you want to see more of jonathan's
take on the firearms of star wars make
sure to subscribe so you can check out
our previous video on the iconic
franchise
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below and if you'd like
to help out the royal armouries museum
and continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
growing the a280 is another
old-school star wars weapon um we first
see
in empire strikes back so we had um for
the first time we saw
the rebels as an organized military we
saw the a280
effectively assault rifles they're like
laser assault rifles and so it's logical
that they're based
on real world assault rifles dressed up
in the traditional star wars way
now in the actual film there are two
completely different guns used as the
basis for what's at least called
in media the same weapon so the a280
is an ar-15 based one where the body is
an ar-15
and then here it's weirdly
interchangeable with the german
stronger there of the second world war
which slightly more fits the star wars
aesthetic i think
so that the one that they chose for the
battlefront games was the
the stromga bear so it's sort of it of
all of the star wars
weapons the real world gun fits this the
sci-fi role
the best i would suggest
okay paul's there so then the next gun
we see there
is i had to look this up i must admit i
am a star wars fan but obviously not not
good enough a star wars fan this is the
rt 97
um heavy blaster but this is um based on
the second world war
german mg15 aircraft machine gun lends
itself quite well to being dressed up as
a
sci-fi gun albeit they didn't really do
that much to it
it's almost as it would be taken from an
aircraft with the exception of the scope
and scove mount and we see this a lot
with star wars weapons that
the major dressing up parts if you like
are
a scope and scope mount of some kind
because back in the 70s and 80s early
80s
infantry tight weapons with optical
sights were not
not at all common and it immediately
makes something look more
futuristic an interesting point actually
for in terms of gameplay i think
is must be a challenge for the
developers to
to sort of balance the weapons without
them all being very similar because we
see a lot of the same
class of weapon being used well i
suppose you have the artistic license of
rate of fire
power of shots color of laser bolts
alt-fire modes
all of that but on the face of it a lot
of them are the same you know they do
the same job that's just got me thinking
about
gameplay versus reality and also
in this case fantasy
okay so this one is a fairly iconic
staple of the star wars universe the dlt
19d
which is we think for gameplay reasons
a designation designated marksman's
rifle maybe that's what the d
stands for i don't know the first order
in that era of the star wars universe
have not been shown to have
an accurate or precision rifle so
they've taken
what is actually an original trilogy
design the dlt 19
and they've modified that it's obviously
still in service 30 years
later and it's been modified with i'm
not really sure what other than a scope
which is obviously important for an
accurate rifle
so to the dlt 19 the the traditional one
which which
um i grew up on as it were seeing
stormtroopers carrying that
it's very it's barely modified mg34
now because it's it uses uh plasma or
whatever energy source
there's no belt of ammunition that's
running through it so that instantly
makes it look different anyway but
there's really there's very little
change
we see the bipod folded under the barrel
shroud there i don't think i've ever
seen
a stormtrooper use that which is in
common with their apparently dreadful
training apart from that
um it's a 1930s 792 millimeter german
machine gun
in space
the dh17 blaster pistol
we're introduced to this in a new hope
in the the famous opening scene of that
and it was the the basic design of the
sterling submachine gun
basically the the um the imperial
blaster is that is just a
sterling the rebel equivalent is also
based on the sterling but what they did
for the original movie
was cut it right down added this
distinctive
sort of bullet shaped barrel shroud and
what's called a single point
optical sight but it really was all
about the
visual look of these things i don't
think you ever see anyone use a scope
it seems to be i don't think i used it
when i played this game for a short
period
but it seems to be quite effective for a
pistol
the prequels have their own distinct
aesthetic when it came to the weapons
it's this is an interesting choice for
the calico
many people won't know what the calico
is i'll grab one this is the m961 which
is the submachine gun version
and this this is an interesting
reflection of the the aesthetic they
went for
with the prequel films to distance them
from
what came before they do kind of look
more advanced in some ways
this is a 1980s american submachine gun
slash pistol depending on the
configuration
otherwise not much has changed um the
stock comes off it looks even more like
the one from
the prequels so they fitted a scope to
it for that star wars
look it's already got the foregrip and
then they just added some metal parts
to the plastic parts to make the well to
break up the outline it's almost like
camouflage when you're
designing movie props to fit a certain
aesthetic i suppose
well what can we say about this thing
the the thing about the sequel trilogy
in terms of prop design if i i love most
of the production design of those films
some of the guns are a bit disappointing
and this kind of sums up why really it
sort of doesn't look like much of
anything um it's not based on any real
world gun
everything in star wars has to be based
on something that we recognize but i
always think it lends
a unique look and stops it just being
any old
ray gun from a generic sci-fi property
and unfortunately that's kind of what
this looks like so that's not the fault
of the game
that's the source material i'm quite
happy with the black and white
look to the first order weapons i don't
mind that took me a while to get used to
it but i'm
quite happy with it now but it's just
this boxy contraption and um
just does the same job as say a dlt 19
or something but in a less exciting way
so i can't get too excited about that
one
now this one threw me for a loop because
i didn't recognize it
and i didn't remember its original
incarnation
from star wars jedi knight which i
completed way back in the day
uh so there was an imperial heavy
repeater in that now
when the work there wasn't such a
variety of star wars weapons as there is
now they had to sort of invent a
category for a
rapid fire blaster with a bit more punch
to it i guess
and what they've done for battlefront
the battlefront game is
come up with another new weapon which
we've just seen but it is
quite similar or at least the basic
layout is quite similar
to this imperial heavy repeater from the
old jedi knight games
but they had to change it up because
it's quite low poly model and
not much detail to it so basically the
same basic configuration
but what i like what they've done with
it because they've made it fit much
better than the jedi knight version
which
if anything looks more frequent trilogy
maybe
but this version it's more black it's
got the um
remnant very reminiscent pistol grip
selector switch of the sterling
and the the back end of the actual
receiver is a bit more sterling so it
implies a bit more of a
blast tech lineage there but um yeah i
quite like the look of that
so this this is an interesting one i
don't think i think this is another
invention for the battlefront series
i've said previously that the
cycler rifle is the only gun in the game
that fires a projectile but i'm not so
sure
because this thing i do vaguely remember
from playing the game now that i think
about it
is essentially a space shotgun it
doesn't eject any
any cartridge case of any kind so
perhaps it's caseless
slug throwing technology and is
therefore a projectile weapon like the
cyclo rifle or perhaps it's firing some
sort of concentrated
balls of energy i don't know it doesn't
make a huge amount of sense
in the universe but then things don't
have to make sense slightly reminiscent
of a sparse 12
um and the heat shield on it but it's a
you have to really squint to see that
similarity i think
you need variety in weapons in a video
game and we don't see
shotguns in star wars maybe that means
we shouldn't have shotguns in
battlefront
discuss
uh so the last of the um i'm over using
this word really badly but iconic
star wars weapons is boba fett's blaster
which is fairly unique to him i think in
the star wars universe
and was built by baptian co on a
webley and scott signal pistol you can
definitely see the
um the back of the of the barrel the
frame
i think the hammer is still visible on
on that prop and the thumb hole
stock which replaces the grips because
this is this is
based on the webley mark vi revolver the
mechanism is the same
double action revolver
and it's a convenient way to launch
flares very important for communication
in the first world war because radios
are gigantic and have to be carried by
a donkey or something obviously it's um
an offensive weapon
in the star wars universe and it's
dressed up with a
longer finned barrel the usual gubbins
that are
added to a star wars weapon but
underneath
that's what it is
we are a museum as you know the royal
armouries um if you'd like to to donate
absolutely no pressure to do so but
there are links in the description also
for our membership
scheme we've also started doing a series
of short videos
on our own youtube youtube channel at
the royal armouries so
feel free to check out our youtube
channel as well thanks very much
[Music]
you